supply side problems may have been
holding back our economy maybe they're
easing but the problem is growth is a
function of demand as well as Supply and
to understand what demand means it can
help to look right down at the detail at
individual households ultimately demand
is what we spend
Becks X is a as a graduate she lives in
Liverpool with her two University
friends she earns well 30 000 pounds a
year in her late twenties and crucially
Bex is comfortable even despite recent
cost of living crisis if we look at what
Beck's spending looks like in a typical
month that's her salary there 2500
pounds a month tax rent bills costs
things like Fuel and food the things she
has to pay for still leaves her in a
typical month this year with about 330
pounds in her pocket at the end of the
month enough to go out a couple of times
see friends maybe go to local gigs
mostly local spending and that's
important
here's the challenge on the demand side
economically let's look at the forecast
of what's going to happen to Beck over
the next 12 months so some of her costs
have gone up her salaries increased a
bit but look at the effect of all those
costs editing increases higher energy
costs rental cost increases and of
course the cost of food going up taken
together her spending has almost halved
now that means that she's got a lot less
money in her pocket to spend on the
things she enjoys it means that she's
going to be squeezed to save as much
maybe towards a down payment on her
first flat and it means probably more
nights in Sky movies and baked beans
rather than the local pub
the problem is there are a lot of people
like Becks in the economy and the effect
of all those little decisions that we're
making to spend less is that
cumulatively we're all spending less
we've cut back on non-essential spending
we've cut back on not necessarily or uh
discretionary trips we make we're
spending Less on food substituting more
expensive food for cheaper food and as
that's happening our consumer confidence
has declined that in turn means on the
margin we might prefer to save a bit
more rather than spending a bit more and
that's bad news for the economy and so
when we turn to those GDP statistics
this is what we see we see that
discretionary spending on things like
Arts entertainment Recreation has come
down in August a month when you'd expect
it to be high during good weather we've
also seen things like people deferring
maintenance and essential spending
because if you can defer it people are
deferring it and taking together that
means the GDP numbers have been hit hard
you might expect to see production come
down during the summer months you don't
want to see Services spending come down
during the summer months that's about 80
percent of our whole economy is services
in the UK so that small decrease is a
big deal
and let's look at those GDP numbers that
we've recently discovered look here's
the story we're going right back in time
now to 2008 in the financial crisis
after that nasty period of Falls month
on month we had this period of relative
stability and a relatively flat period
in which growth over about a decade was
about two percent a year
coronavirus hits and of course
tremendous contraction followed by the
boom afterwards but look at this and
this is the puzzle that quasi quateng
and Liz truss face they're avowed intent
to get growth back up to two and a half
percent isn't what we're seeing actually
over the last few months annualized
growth closer to two percent than two
and a half percent and the danger is
with those demand pressures and lower
consumer confidence or you might see
even less growth next year possibly a
contraction and the dreaded r word
recession